kalifornien ärmliche verhältnisse die
herkunft vom quality time genannt pippa
ihrer mutter erdrückt sie mit liebe und
geheimniskrämerei
sie erzählt ihr nicht einmal wer ihr
vater ist für pid eine qual
die junge frau will ihre wahre herkunft
kennen um jeden preis und schließt sich
eine gemeinschaft von
enthüllungsjournalisten an deren
anführer andreas wolf ist ein paranoider
aber charismatischer typ der mit dem
haken digitaler geheimnisse die welt in
atem hält
er benutzt für seine zwecke
einen moment lang war er als hätte man
ihr den schädel aufgeklappt und das
gehirn kräftig mit einem holzlöffel
ungerührt sie war noch immer weit davon
entfernt sich ihn zu unterwerfen
weit davon entfernt leichte beute für
ihn zu sein und doch war er einen moment
lang so tief in ihrem kopf gewesen
der enthüllungsjournalist als kultfigur
unserer zeit der freizonen pflanzen
der weltbekannte autor hat seinen roman
voller gutgeschrieben so sagt er selber
wütend auf die neuen heroen des
internets figuren wir sahen schon
snowden wurden als helden gefeiert
als ich dieses buch schrieb als tolle
vorbilder zur gleichen zeit kannte ich
viele autoren die ihr leben nicht mehr
finanzieren konnten weil das internet
den professionellen freelancer beruf
zerstört hat die enthüller wollen
aufklären
doch die dunklen seiten ihrer eigenen
vergangenheit verleugnen und
verschleiern sie sie manipulieren sich
gegenseitig und lassen sich einspannen
das macht sie bei fremden zu schuldigen
und die lichtgestalt des whistleblowers
ist sein antiheld
da ist dieser mythos dass wir uns nur
die ganze zeit entblößen müssen damit
die welt besser wird
das ärgert mich denn so viel in unsere
zivilisation hängt davon ab was wir
nicht sagen was wir nicht sagen wollen
und nicht sein müssen macht und
kontrolle geheimnis und verrat fransen
vergleich das internet mit einem
totalitären system wie die ddr eines war
die gewagte these kommt nicht von
ungefähr
der autor hat in den frühen 80er jahren
in berlin studiert kennt die geschichte
der deutschen trennung gut
whistleblower andreas wolf hat denn auch
eine ostdeutsche biografie er wächst auf
als privilegierter verwöhnter sohn eines
stasi funktionärs über verhüllung
bespitzelung und manipulation weiß wolf
vom kindesbeinen an bescheid
doch er hadert mit seinen eltern wie
viele figuren bei fransen er rebelliert
gegen seinen vater wird zum dissidenten
und gar zu mörder mit seiner
besitzergreifenden mutter verbindet ihn
eine hassliebe die sein leben prägt
nichts an andreas kindheit mit ihr war
gewöhnlich
sie erlaubte ihm alles und verlangte
dafür lediglich dass er ständig bei ihr
bleiben wollte nur dass er sie
anhimmelte das anhimmeln erfolgte ganz
von selbst
packend über 800 seiten hinweg erzählt
der autor von drängenden themen unserer
zeit von internet abhängigkeit von
beziehungskrisen und zerrütteten
familien banden
es gibt keine stabile familie mehr in
meinem buch anders als in den büchern
zuvor einfach weil ich den sehr vielen
merkwürdigen familienkonstellation
rechnung tragen will das modell vater
mutter zwei drei vier kinder ist nicht
mehr die regel
im roman scheint beziehungsunfähigkeit
vererbt zu werden ob großeltern eltern
oder kinder keine beziehung ist mehr
glücklich allein der stellungskrieg
einer zerg welten ehe die einst als
große liebe begann nimmt 200 seiten ein
schreckliche beziehungen sind doch
dadurch geprägt wie lange sie andauern
und wie unauflöslich sie sich anfühlen
so was kann man nicht schnell erzählen
obwohl pip das dunkle geheimnis ihrer
herkunft schließlich lüftet ihre prägung
wird sie nicht los
ihr bleibt nur das prinzip hoffnung es
müsste doch möglich sein es besser als
ihre eltern zu machen
aber sie war sich nicht sicher ob sie es
konnte franzens roman berührt und
beunruhigt rührt an wunde stellen des
menschlichen zusammenlebens
das macht ihn doppelt lesenswert